we've come to island on a quest to find
the best steak in the world with a man
who's tucked into his fair share of them
over the years PJ sorry is a self-made
millionaire and founder of German
Gourmet magazine Fla young sake Irish
are said to have very happy cattle I'd
like to see for myself it's also said
their steaks are second to none the pink
lemon Ireland is the largest exporter of
beef in the EU it's home to six and a
half million cattle Paul Farrell's farm
is in County Kilkenny in the southeast
of the country
this is our best pole this is a
neighboring Aberdeen Angus pole he's not
your traditional Angus bull he's more
he's bigger than normal but he's still
easy calving and an easy fleshy abolish
is an animal and he's working now and
this is his this was her he wore so you
have to be careful with the ball and
give them respect and that includes
giving natural feed not concentrated
pellets or vitamin supplements grass is
the most important paradise forage makes
up ninety-five percent of their days so
we try to incorporate clover into our
grass mixtures or we incorporate over to
it and it helps to the clover helps to
fix the nitrogen from the air so there
by using less chemical fertilizer it
also helps to ensure optimum fat
distribution in the animals so does that
explain the exquisite taste of the meat
bj's a prey wants to find out the facts
on the ground find among the best steak
in the world at your place well maybe
not in the world but we will have a go
and see what we have okay you're very
welcome it comes right thank you Paul's
wife Nicola certainly has a
world-beating method for cooking their
steaks fri open the pan at 140 degrees
celsius seasoning with salt and pepper
and then adding onions and red peppers
and pull up disgustin very geeky smells
absolutely delicious
vijay's already looking forward to
savoring the steak the aroma alone had
his mouth watering and now he gets to
sink his teeth into it hmm it's really
perfect so I'm dissing to assure its
good plan it was perhaps a tad overdone
but still very tasty you can tell it's
relatively young meat and it was not dry
matured it still has this slightly
watery touch it basically goes on Z if
you have to remember that meat can taste
different than we become used to but
there are other contenders for the best
steak on the planet Madras has been a
family-run butcher since 1900
yes ha I've heard the you folks are the
experts for dry mature Irish beef right
beef I don't know what experts know but
we we draw a jurors be far I
traditionally what do you care to show
me some of this yeah no bank officer in
the beef industry meet its age to
varying degrees initially tough right
after slaughter it's the biochemical
reactions during the maturing process
that soften the muscles oh wow what an
aroma we're gonna be the oldest beef
that's three weeks old or three and a
half weeks old and that's a hindquarter
and that's a fourth one how do you get
that great aroma just time time time
time and fat and that's a little
corporal of five is what that's why the
flavors yes so far so good Vijay can
tell that Ireland has no shortage of
quality cattle nor of quality butchers
what's missing is the perfect
preparation and dismiss unrealistic
nothing it has to taste like beef so
that you can just about imagine the barn
was to income McGraw's butchers supply
beef to the top restaurants in Ireland
among them is trocadero in Dublin head
chef ik Yamba Sheena joined the team
here 13 years ago and is famed for her
steaks
I'm looking for really good steak oh
that's mean you had a right place every
evening the restaurant serves in excess
of 200 Phyllis takes putting the cell
from both sides very little video oil
and let sulekha been making nice and
brown and crispy the steak sizzles away
until nicely done Vijay safra can hardly
wait and then finally possibly the best
steak in the world is on its way to his
table enjoy your food thank you on the
visual front the state gets top marks
but what would our culinary expert make
of the quality on the inside as Irish
make tests missin you can really taste
the meadowlands boy that's brilliant Lee
done fried to perfection it doesn't get
much better than us and console if you
Beth are constantly making Vijay's trip
to Ireland most worthwhile and it's
definitely whet his appetite for even
more steak in the future